okay we do have a discussion forum set
up using the infrastructure of Reddit
you can go to david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT a couple of interesting posts i
spotted this morning on the david pakman
show subreddit one asking in the midst
of this massive stock correction that
we're seeing well it's not that massive
yet we've lost like the last two months
of gains but we'll see how tomorrow goes
right the question is how does the stock
market affect ordinary people this is a
good question because we've talked
before about how stock ownership is
concentrated hugely at the top of the
income distribution right like the the
it's the wealthy who own the
overwhelming majority of stocks so the
average person is impacted by stock
market declines in a couple ways number
one if you have any kind of retirement
plan at all through an employer through
a 403b if you're an education 401k if
you've just got some mutual funds you
are going to lose value when the stock
market goes down and even if for a rich
person that wouldn't be a lot of money
for the average middle class person the
amount of money that they do have in
mutual funds or stocks is important to
them so that's number one number two is
that when stock markets drop this
impacts how corporations spend money and
think about their financial situation so
even if you don't own the stocks raises
could be impacted by the fact that a
company's market value has dropped
drastically because of a stock market
decline so there's the the direct and
the indirect ways in which even ordinary
people are affected by stock market
declines and if this keeps going the way
it's been going the last few days
certainly it's something that we're
going to be talking about more also from
the david pakman show subreddit the idea
of cracking down on white collar crime
as a national message for 2020
presumably for the left I've actually
been thinking for a while that taking an
approach of we are against crony
corruption we are going to crack down on
white collar crime could actually be an
interesting campaign idea for the left
writ large now you might say it's not a
very not a very sexy issue it's not a
very attractive issue that that maybe
would get people to vote look at all the
issues that we know don't get people to
vote that the left sometimes focuses on
so I actually do think that an anti
corruption anti crony capitalist we're
gonna crack down on white-collar
criminals is listen how much worse could
it get it's a it's worth trying at least
this message actually kind of worked for
Trump in a sense anyway swamp it was a
lie supposedly what that was all about
but yeah it was a bogus promise I think
it's an interesting idea and I encourage
I encourage the left to think about it
join these and other discussions or
create your own by visiting david
pakman.com slash re d di t